wonder Fanta don't you want a want a
Fanta don't know this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey I'm Blake and I'm American
hi I'm Sheree I'm from Scotland and
we're going to be swapping snacks I'm
honestly originally from Scotland have
been in LA but seven years I mess my
snacks so this is a very good day it's
like the same difference
all right I'm trying I'm excited to try
these snacks let's get to it
[Music]
I got the Lay's kettle cooked couple
years ago they set the game up you know
cuz the bag harder to get into this is a
sea salt and cracked pepper the good one
is a very good one we have here Mackie's
of Scotland haggis and cracked black
pepper okay I've definitely feel this
it's gonna be very interesting
what does haggis me Pacus is I would say
Google after this wait but that's that's
not no no this is just the imitation
flavor crunchy peppery
these are definitely a bit more on
dictation safe there's no like flavor
punch really yeah it's not as much I
feel like bad about this I feel like
there's so much more oh so much better
it's like everything that I wish it ship
could be it doesn't have too much grease
or oil like my hands are so pretty like
these are life ya see what it needs more
crunch no like this is a great reason
[Music]
some allure not like crazy yeah I would
say we're we're both in agreement that
they're both good yes I'm gonna go with
the flavorful haggis ghosts a trade in
my country this one I'm gonna go with
the flavorful haggis as well actually
see ya
I love Milano's Scottish shortbread it's
got chocolate chips in it which isn't
really the traditional kind as much but
this is good to dip into milk maybe even
a couple petite
nice little English English breakfast
goes with coffee or like hot chocolate
really well I think you're gonna like
this this is just perfect to have on the
weekends morning cup of coffee dip this
biscuit in there just double milk
chocolate I'm good
noodles Bon Appetit milano irresistible
so why is this mine's a lot bigger don't
know if that's appropriate but I'm sold
two bites in right good
oh this is fantastic I love this I would
probably swap my coffee morning routine
with that to this because if it's not a
sweet where's I actually might swap
those because I like the sugar do you
have tea at home of course like you like
to sit at home and have it oh yeah
absolutely that's that's what we grew up
with having like your anterior uncle
comes over do you want a cup of tea
you gave him a cup of tea what's the
dipping ratio on this how many seconds
maybe not as quick as you would think
but you do still need to be quick yeah
[Music]
beating us down right now
yeah we've got some good snacks do you
say that warming don't you know dumpkins
of decide in Scotland
make sure not to shock sad weird
Duncan's are better than Milano's I love
the shortbread but I've had a lots going
up so I'm gonna swap and I'm gonna keep
these yeah and then actually same reason
for him I'm gonna go with these because
I've had those all the time and these
are different and I like it it's
different in a good way and the dipping
ratio is longer yeah
[Music]
the life elixir item Bree I have not
seen this for such a long time and now I
get little over RN brew Fanta vodka
vodka don't you want touch I love orange
soda and I'm gonna have to blame that on
Kel Mitchell please play that clip I'm
so excited to try this I want it to cure
my life it's gonna kick your leg Cheers
to international relations to cult being
cultured fizzy sweet I'm cured
oh so it's like a cream soda cream soda
I don't even know that it's orange like
one thing you know it's it's one thing
no it tastes like cream soda yeah I just
want to point out that this is energy
20,000 20,000 volts of energy this is
incredible
I mean the fence is good it's refreshing
but the whole time I'm just ready for
this moment in my life so cheers man you
took a big gold - have you been missing
it I gotta say though after like the
first second or third step it's starting
to get a little bit more mediciney come
on there's something weird there's
almost it's almost like medicine your
mom yo to you on the spoon
tastes like iron brew I mean the closest
I could compare this to would be of
course the Fanta but it just tastes like
orange like the color orange that's a
good description yeah and it's not as
busy as like a normal and I think that's
what I like about it too because the
fizz and fancily makes you want to burn
stuff I have to use the one I prefer I
prefer Fanta I know I know is that
sugary goodness
you're so disappointed in Scotland's
been doing great but I think that we got
them on the sugary soft drinks overall
I'm gonna say that I like the Scottish
presentation of everything a little bit
better the cookies were definitely
better way way better not that surprised
that I would prefer most of the Scottish
sax they weren't as oily or greasy for
the chips and then for the shortbread it
wasn't as sweet and that was kind of
nice you know but that iron Bru
beautiful beautiful I'm gonna need a
little bit of time with that one I mean
pretty biased to my snacks I'm not gonna
lie I'm not sure how cool that is of me
but I am I'm pretty biased to them so
yeah I'll leave it at that
leave it at that
[Music]
you
[Music]